[Music]  Josh Duhamel and Fergie might just be  two of the friendliest exes in Hollywood  the pair split in September 2017 after  eight years of marriage but when the  singer faced backlash for her  performance of the national anthem at  the NBA all-star game on Sunday night  Josh showed up to her house on Monday  with a bouquet of red and pink roses and  a card that read I love you the  transformer star was dropping off their  four-year-old son Axl who also carried a  card that read I love you always and  forever mommy complete with a smiley  face in a statement to ET on Monday the  Fergalicious star acknowledged the  criticism surrounding her jazzy  rendition of the star-spangled banner  explaining that she tried her best to  bring something special to the event  [Music]  I'm a risk-taker artistically but  clearly this rendition didn't strike the  intended tone adding I love this country  and honestly tried my best  you